it is therefore the outcome was as
expected Donald John Trump be and he is
hereby acquitted of the charges in said
articles Donald Trump only the third
u.s. president to be impeached now also
the third US president to be acquitted
the White House called it full of
indication and exoneration mr. Romney
all but one Republican senator voted not
guilty on both articles of impeachment
the lone defector was MIT Romney the
Utah senator who in 2012 was the
Republican presidential nominee my faith
is at the heart of who I am Romney said
in an emotional floor speech his
conscience was more important than party
loyalty he voted guilty on abuse of
power what he did was not perfect no it
was a flagrant assault under electoral
rights our national security and our
fundamental values a few other
Republicans said they believed what
Trump did was wrong but didn't rise to
removal from office others blasted the
Democrats efforts to remove the 45th US
president I worry about the future the
presidency after what's happened here
ladies and gentlemen you will come to
regret this whole process all Democrats
voted to convict Trump on both charges
they voiced disappointment after his
acquittal but did not admit defeat Trump
me yet faced further investigations in
the Democrat controlled house and make
no mistake about it the drip drip drip
of evidence is going to keep coming out
with each new revelation the message to
the House of Representatives don't do
this again
now with the impeachment officially
behind him Trump can spring toward the
November election whether all this has
helped him or hurt him as a candidate is
the big question
Heidi Joe Castro al Jazeera Washington